Hello Fabrice and Jerry,
director of the frontex agency
untildeux-mille-vingt-deux.
Frontex is the European station agency,
of border and coast station.
In principle,
it helps
States to
control borders against illegal immigration,
against crime
international,
and helps states to
deport illegal migrants.
My assessment,
at the head of Frontex,
I fought in cooperation with the States to
increase evictions,
to strengthen border controls,
to create the body
European border guard and coast guard in
armed uniform,
to develop the ability to
border surveillance with aircraft,
with funny,
satellite images.
Because I wanted to protect Europe from the
migratory trader.
For more than 2 years,
I suffered the pressures of the
European Commission and O. M.
G. And in fact,
for the European Union,
immigration is not a problem,
it is a project.
Emmanuel Macron beat the
immigration records in France
and during the presidency
of the European Union,
was contact director.
And I can testify that Emmanuel Macron and his
government
have continued to abandon the sovereignty of France,
particularly in the field of immigration.
The commission,
with its asylum and migration pact,
wants to impose on Frontex to be the
cab of illegal immigration.
And once illegal migrants are in Europe,
the commission
wants to require states to accept migrants.
And if 1 state refuses 1 migrant,
he must pay €20,000 per refused migrant.
All this with the taxpayer's money
The European Union claims
control illegal immigration,
but unfortunately, the
European Commission
transformed frontex into a super oung for microphones.
The European Commission makes us believe
that it is not possible to
control borders,
or it is not true and I can explain why
it is possible
to fight against mass immigration.
But you still have to want it.
First,
controlling borders
with the help of frontex
in the framework of cooperation with other States,
then reform the Sharingan space
to find out who is coming to France
and finally organize in France 1 tournament.
Resume control of our migration policy.
I have decided to commit myself
with Jordan Bardella and Marine Le Pen
to save Europe from immigration.
On nine/06/01,
only round,
Only 1 useful vote against Macron's Europe,
vote for the list of Jordan Bardella